I have to ask you a question that uh
somebody in our amazing team wanted to
ask
he's happily married another like you
mentioned incredible relationship are
they good friends are there Amazing
Friends there you go but okay I'm not
saying who it is so I can say some stuff
which is they it started out as a great
uh sexual connection oh well there you
go but then became very close friends
after that listen there you go uh So
speaking of sex
he was uh he has a wonderful son and
he's wanting to have a second kid and he
wanted to ask the great Andrew huberman
is there uh like sexual positions or any
kind of thing that can help
maximize the chance that they have a
girl versus a boy because they're a
wonderful boy they want a girl is there
is there a way to control the gender
this has been debated for a long time
and I did a uh four and a half hour
episode on fertility and the reason I
did a four and a half hour episode
fertility is that first of all I find
that the reproductive biology be
fascinating and I wanted a resource for
people that
um were thinking about or struggling
with having kids uh for whatever reason
um and it felt important to me to
combine the male and female components
in the same episode it's all time
stamped so you don't have to listen to
the whole thing we talk about IVF in
Virtual fertilization and we talk about
natural pregnancy okay the data on
position is very interesting but let me
just say a few things there are a few
clinics now in particular some out of
the United States that are spinning down
sperm and finding that they can separate
out fractions as they're called you know
they can spin the sperm down at a given
speed and they'll separate out at
different
um sort of depths within the test tube
that allow them to pull out the sperm on
top or below and bias the probability
towards male or female births it's not
perfect it's not 100 it's a very costly
procedure it's still very controversial
um now with in vitro fertilization I can
extract eggs you can do introduce a
sperm directly by pipette it's a process
called ixy or you can set up a sperm
race in a dish and if you get a number
of different embryos
um meaning the eggs get fertilized to
duplicate and for start to form a
blastocyst which is a ball of cells
early embryo then you can do karyotyping
so you can do look for XX or XY select
the XY which then would give rise to a
male offspring and then plant that one
so there is that kind of sex selection
um
with respect to position there's a lot
of lore that you know if
um the woman is on top or the woman's on
the bottom or whether or not the
penetration is from behind whether or
not it's going to be male or female
Offspring and frankly the data are not
great as you can imagine because those
those would be interesting studies to
run perhaps
um there is studies there is paper there
are some there are they're not I guess
yeah there's more lore than science and
there's a lot of and there are a lot of
other variables that are hard to control
so for instance if it if it's um
ejaculation during intermission during
during sex penetration Etc
um
then you can't measure for instance
sperm volume as opposed to when it's IVF
and they can actually measure how many
milliliters how many forward motile
sperm it's hard to control for for
certain things and um this can vary
between individuals and even from one
ejaculation to the next and okay so
there's too many variables however the
position thing is interesting
in the following way
um and then I'll answer whether or not
you can bias towards a female
um as long as we're talking as long as
we're trying I have other questions
about sex but as long as we're talking
about sexual position all right there
are data
that support the idea that in order to
increase the probability of successful
fertilization
that indeed the woman should not stand
upright after sex
and should right after right after the
man is ejaculated inside her and should
adjust her pelvis say 15 degrees upwards
I mean you know
some of the fertility experts MDS will
say that's crazy you know but others
that I
sought out and not specifically for this
answer but for researching that episode
said that yeah you know what you're
talking about is trying to get the
maximum number of sperm and it's
contained in semen and yes the semen can
leak out and so keeping um the pelvis
tilted for about at 15 degrees for about
15 minutes obviously tilted in the
direction that would have things running
Upstream not Downstream so to speak
would gravity it's real
um you know
um so so for maximizing uh fertilization
you know that the doctors I spoke to
just said look given that if people are
trying to get pregnant what is spending
15 minutes on their back
um you know this sort of thing okay so
then with respect to there to female
getting a female Offspring or XX
female Offspring
um
selectively there is the idea that as
fathers get older they're more likely to
have daughters as opposed to Sons that's
a from the papers I've read is a
significant but still mildly significant
result so at with each passing year
um this person increases the probability
they're gonna have a daughter not a son
look um so that's interesting but the
probability differences are probably
tiniest I mean it's it's not you know
it's a signif it's not trivial it's not
a trivial difference
um but if they want to ensure having
a daughter then they should do IVF and
select an xxm um embryo and um when you
go through IVF they genetically screen
them for karyotype which is xxxy
um and they look at mutations genotypic
mutations for things like you know
trisomies and the employees all the
stuff you don't want
but there is a lot of lore if you look
on the internet sure different foods uh
so a lot of variables there's a lot of
area but there haven't been systematic
studies so
um I think probably the best thing to do
unless they're going to do IVF is just
you know roll the dice and um you know
and I think uh with each passing year
they increase the probability of getting
a female Offspring
um and with but of course with each
passing year the egg and sperm quality
degrade so you know get after it soon